espiral de violencia en el noreste de
colombia desde el principio del año 86
personas fueron asesinadas en el
departamento de arauca -fronterizo con
venezuela- y escenario de una rivalidad
entre el ejército de liberación nacional
ln y las disidencias de las farc
el ministro colombiano de defensa diego
molano y el ministro del interior daniel
palacios dirigieron un consejo de
seguridad en la localidad de tame aquí
las disidencias de las farc lln y la
nueva marquetalia generan homicidios a
sus mismos hombres
y en ese sentido seguiremos trabajando
la mano de la fuerza pública aunque el
grueso de los rebeldes de las farc se
desmovilizó en 2017 algunas disidencias
quedaron activas y luchan desde
principios de enero contra miembros de
la ln por el control de la región que
constituye una zona importante para el
narcotráfico la situación supone un duro
golpe para la vida cotidiana y la
economía de la zona debido a la guerra
los programas
de orden público mucho negocio cerrado
mucho comercio cerrado la mayoría de
personas han tocado cerrado negocios
entregar locales
el presidente colombiano iván duque
culpa a régimen de nicolás maduro de
proteger a los grupos armados y al mismo
tiempo es acusado desde venezuela vemos
en el presidente de colombia
un nivel de desesperación absoluta
camino electoral que se ha abierto en
colombia bueno ha provocado un terror un
ambiente de terror y de desesperación la
oligarquía colombiana los gobiernos de
colombia y venezuela no tienen
relaciones diplomáticas desde el 2018